[Musique]
c'est dur de trouver des places pour se
garer
mais c'est interdit hewitt on voit tu
l'as mérité sa contravention
[Musique]
attention au feu rouge pour creux de
chiens les passes à travers le
pare-brise deuxième contravention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
troisième contravention
trois contrats passés dans la journée ça
coûte cher
[Musique]
chacun son tour sac à dos
que se passe-t-il une attaque de banque
[Musique]
bravo tu vois tu es courageux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh là là tantôt est pris en otage
pour tonton soit
[Musique]
wa tumba tous souffle du gaz hilarant
voilà le résultat
[Rires]
en votant au revoir
[Applaudissements]
il
où
et
oh